all right people of the internet you've
asked for it it's finally time I've put
it off I did not want to do this video
because I'm afraid you guys are gonna be
mad at me I I really am afraid you're
gonna be upset so if you missed the
previous videos we did on this basically
after we got the initial look at the
Hogwarts Legacy common rooms I'm talking
the very brief Glimpse I did a tier list
breaking it down telling you guys which
ones were my favorite based off that
very limited look well now that we've
gotten a full common room reveal I've
broken all of them down we found all the
little secrets now I am ready you guys
to do my official tier list and of
course we may have to do one of these
again when the game actually comes out
because there are things that we didn't
see in that little preview but I have to
say you may be surprised to know that my
opinion actually has changed quite a bit
in some areas not so much in others but
let's not waste any more time let's Dive
Right In so here I am in Affinity photo
I've got the four houses here and can I
just say right off the bat I do not
think there's a bad Common room I really
don't and I'm not saying that just
please everybody trust me you're going
to be plenty mad as we go throughout the
video I can I can see all the fights
breaking out between the houses now in
the comments but in all honesty you guys
like if I belonged to any of these
houses I would be very very pleased with
the common room I just think they have
done such a phenomenal job so I mean I
think at bare minimum bare minimum I'm
gonna put everything at least at a B
right here at least at a B certainly no
D's and certainly no C's I mean we may
see as we go through here I may even
eventually bump everything up to it at
least an A but we're gonna go through
one by one we can Shuffle and change
this as we go but I really did struggle
when I was trying to decide how am I
going to do this do I base it off of
you know uniqueness do I base it off how
true it is to the book there are so many
subjective factors here that you know
it's impossible to be objective with
this so I'm just going to say straight
up that I ultimately decided to do this
based on where I would most enjoy to
sleep and to live if I was attending a
school but which one of these would I be
most comfortable in and just really have
the overall best time in you know
meeting new people getting to talk to
people but also study and all of those
things feel comfortable where would it
go so let's start off with Slytherin
here so in any Hogwarts test I have ever
done I am always lowest in Slytherin so
I am the exact opposite of
in terms of the traits and everything
you know maybe I have some Slytherin
qualities but for the most part it's
always low on my list now there are
things about their common room that I
actually did like quite a bit first of
all I love the underwater feel and how I
mean they nailed that in terms of book
accuracy I think it looks fantastic when
you're walking into that room and you've
got the stone but I mean you need light
right you need some source of light and
that at least provides some source of
light however for me personally I do not
think I would like being underground I I
just wouldn't I would not like that I
would need even more light than what
that's able to give I mean think about
at night and of course it is Hogwarts
it's Enchanted they're going to be
plenty of ways that I don't know you can
bewitch the glass to make it look like
it's always sunny and shiny I don't know
there there are ways around that I get
it but going off the look that we saw
there I'm trying to just think okay if
it was night there's not going to be a
lot of light getting in through there
now some other things that I just
personally for me I really do not love
all the animal skulls I mean that would
freak me out animal skulls everywhere
serpents everywhere I mean I counted
more than 20 when I was doing my full
breakdown video that is does not jive
with who I am serpents all over the
place so for me right now I'm Gonna
Leave Slytherin at B uh and say it would
be the least one uh least least one the
least likely it'd be the last one that I
would want to actually live in put it
that way okay the next one I want to
talk about is Hufflepuff here now
Hufflepuff was actually at the top of my
last list when we did this the first
time and I'm gonna go ahead right away
and bump them to an a here I just think
they have done such a fantastic job with
bringing this common room to life and I
know it's not truly the first time we've
seen it but I do think it's it's the
first time we've seen it in such detail
and they have just done such an amazing
job I mean it really does feel like you
have these little Burrows once we've
actually been able to see the full
reveal of the common room these little
Burrows and just this overall communal
feel of the common room there's so much
life here I think that's what they're
really going for with all of the plants
that are about they even have little
snacks around on the table being so
close to the kitchen of course the
hufflepuffs are going to have snacks
right I mean you have to have snacks if
you're that close to the Hogwarts
kitchens some things I don't like uh
honestly all the plants being around I
would just be sneezing constantly I know
I would I'm highly allergic to a lot of
different they I'm allergic to Grass you
guys pretty much all types of grass so
I'd be spending so much time in the
hospital Wing asking them to make me
some sort of specialized I don't know
specialized potion anti-allergy potion
to make me be able to survive the
Hufflepuff common room but again I I
talked about on the Slytherin common
room how I wouldn't like being
underground and so I don't think it's
fair to say I would like that for
hufflepuffs either even though the
hufflepuffs is definitely more of a
bright earthy feel it is still
underground and I just wouldn't like
that I would not like constantly being
underground every night and another
thing for me that was a little bit
disappointing with the Hufflepuff common
room is the fact that they did not have
as many Secrets I don't know little fun
details to find when I was going through
and do doing that video recap breaking
down all the different sections of the
common room you know every little shot
that we were able to get a look at and I
just didn't get the feel that Hufflepuff
had as many Secrets now when the game
comes out I could very well be wrong
there could be a lot of things that we
end up finding there but at least in
terms of just that initial video the
scenes that we were able to view in the
trailer there just wasn't as many in
points of interest I guess would be a
good way to refer to it whereas the
other common rooms I felt like there
were constantly little things here and
there that were jumping out at me as
interesting now I'm not a Hufflepuff so
maybe if we're Hufflepuff there are a
lot more things that you found
interesting and that jumped out at you
in that trailer but for me not as much
as the others okay next we have
Ravenclaw here now Ravenclaw you know
what I'm gonna go ahead I gotta put it
above Hufflepuff I gotta put it above
Hufflepuff here uh the Ravenclaw common
room one thing that it immediately has
going for it is just the source of light
I mean it's so bright it's so well
organized too it's elegant everything is
spaced out nice and neat I was a fairly
studious individual going through school
so I think I would have liked having the
study areas but for me it doesn't quite
Elevate to S tier because it's almost
too proper I I would constantly be going
around the Ravenclaw common room just
feeling like I'm gonna break something
and there I don't know a prefix is going
to be upset with me if I do that they're
gonna come after me and I'm gonna be in
trouble I think the best way for me to
describe the Ravenclaw common room is it
really feels like a super nice museum it
doesn't feel like a place I would want
to actually live and stay and again
that's maybe just me I would totally
love to visit though I'd love to visit
check out your common room but then only
hang out for a few hours and then I
gotta go back to my common room you guys
which is Gryffindor yes I'm a Gryffindor
I'm trying not to let the Buy highest
show here but I was pretty disappointed
honestly after that first look at
Gryffindor I just thought you know what
they're not really showing us a whole
lot here and it's such a hard one to do
because we've seen it so many times it's
the common room that we know better than
any other but I have to put it at s tier
man I really do after we got this full
reveal it is 100 the common room that I
would most want to spend my time in
there's just no doubt about that the the
one problem that I have with it is the
the rugs all over the place
I do think that sort of a disorganized
nature would start to wear on me a bit
but again if I'm having to choose
between that one and the Ravenclaw one
which was just super proper all the time
I'm going with Gryffindor that's where I
could be more comfortable and that is
the name of the game with the Gryffindor
common room I think is it just it puts
Comfort above everything else you know
having the carpets there having those
nice comfortable chairs you were always
going to have a place that you can sit
down relax hang out with some friends
the fire oh I love the fire in the
Gryffindor common room I could just
visualize man I could see the snow
falling down outside it's really cold
and me and a couple of friends are just
sort of gathered around the fire there
sipping on some hot cocoa and I also
have to point out that of all the
Hogwarts houses at least the common
rooms gryffindors more than any other
reflex school spirit you don't see it
with any of the common rooms actually
but with Gryffindor they actually have
the Hogwarts crest there they actually
have the other house crests featured
throughout their common room on certain
banners as well they really seem to
appreciate history tree with Gryffindor
I mean that also goes when you have all
those portraits as well so let's give
one final look at this and see if this
matches up with my rankings and how I
would actually feel Gryffindor 100 is
the one where I would want to live where
I want to spend most of my time if I was
actually attending Hogwarts uh number
two here for sure yep it would
definitely be Ravenclaw even though it's
a little too prim and proper for me I
still give it the edge over Hufflepuff
again the plants all those plants all
over the place I mean having a couple
plants is one thing but having that many
I mean I'm just I'm just getting joked
up thinking about it I could definitely
see myself hanging out with some friends
though in a Hufflepuff and having a good
time and Hufflepuff for sure you feel
like you could be more yourself you know
you could let loose a little bit whereas
in the Ravenclaw common room you've sort
of always got to be on your best
behavior and then Slytherin I mean
honestly you guys like I I don't dislike
the Slytherin common room but if I am
ranking these with the the criteria that
I'm using of the house that I would most
want to live in and hang out in I mean
it's got to be Slytherin because of all
those things makes just the the cold
feel of it I'm constantly cold anyway
and that common room just looks super
cold to me whereas Gryffindor and
Hufflepuff both look so warm ravenclaws
probably looks a little bit cooler than
the others but one look at the
Gryffindor common room and you just know
how warm it's gonna be but I really do
mean what I said in the beginning I
think all of these common rooms are
fantastic so hopefully you guys won't be
too hard on me in the comments
definitely let me know what you think
let me know which one is your favorite
and if you haven't checked out my full
breakdown of all four of these common
rooms I go super in depth I'm gonna put
all four of those on your screen now and
you can choose whichever one you would
like to watch as always thank you all so
much for watching this video I'll talk
to you again soon